in order for the left to be vital it
would have to return to some version of
you know and this is where the right has
much more energy a popular protest
movement I don't understand why you know
people loosely alive with the left are
kind of the party of you know the status
quo
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Chris layman a
journalist who's worked for Mother Jones
in these times tikkun the Washington
Post New York Magazine and is written
for publications ranging from suck to
the Baffler to Reason magazine chris is
currently working at yahoo news and book
for him and he's the author of the new
book collection rich people things the
columns are reflections on things that
kind of wealthy but they're about
experiences as well right right you've
got a chapter 9 r and as well which is
pretty caustic what's wrong with Rand
and her fans for you to me reading Iran
personally is kind of like taking a bad
acid trip that I see this vision of the
world where you know and at the level of
fiction individual characters ironically
for a writer who so elevates
self-interest as the the main principle
of life as far as I can make out many of
these characters are disfigured by
ideology to the point that they don't
act in their own self-interest and it's
just weird paradox I don't really
understand what world I'm I'm being
introduced and it and and all the
speechifying makes me crazy all that all
that loving depictions of metal alloys
or whatever you know well what is it
about the people i mean because she's a
rich people thing in your book what is
it that that people are you know are
worshipping about well i think you know
it is again this kind of mythic idea of
a in a primordial human order that
exists exists in the state of nature
before government where you know there
are individualist geniuses who are
misunderstood by the the sort of lower
rabble who surround them or all scheming
bureaucrats or you know intellectuals
who are out to you know smuggle so
socialism into the world and it's a you
know simultaneously kind of if this
makes sense like naive and paranoid you
know one of the things that i think
about brandon i'm not particularly a fan
of her fiction although really
interested by the fact that she and i'd
say Kerouac is the other writer from
that era who still inspire tons of
people and it's very much about the
individual versus the group and it can
be
an uptight society or it can be a
government or it can be you know
whatever but you know does that salvage
her at all I do think there is something
there that it you know both ran and
kerouac speak to this kind of you know
you can say it's kind of a warped
Emersonian tradition in American letters
and which Emerson was himself pretty
pretty damn worked i had well you have a
chapter in the book about Rand Paul he's
almost certain to become the next
senator from Kentucky will that be such
a bad thing for the country or for you
or for black people I don't think so and
I think one returns to these debates
over race with a certain weariness
because I do actually think the country
has advanced in a certain way and I I
sort of say in the book what was i mean
the the comments on the Civil Rights Act
I thought were illuminating because they
seemed to betray you know for whatever
reason as I think I said in the book
Rand Paul seemed to have this vision of
Jim Crow is something enacted almost
entirely by government institutions like
a clan sponsor version of the the
Tennessee Valley Authority and obviously
the first sit-ins were at Woolworth
counters you know private enterprise was
very deeply implicated room in Jim Crow
and and that and it's more that ideology
that you know the somehow the
institutions of the private sector are
always virtuous that the state is always
this vampire like figure but I think
what's also more interesting about Rand
Paul was he you know his comments when
Obama you know criticized BP at the
height of the spill as you know
anti-business and therefore
anti-american and that to me signal them
a much broader kind of shifting
political consensus and it probably is
why he will be the next senator senator
because we do have this kind of fall
back belief that to be anti-business is
to to violate the the sort of sacred
precepts of our founding these are kind
of a right-wing for lack of a better
term right-wing rich people things what
do you do with you know say rich people
thing is something like Michelle Obama's
vacation now I get on the Democratic
Party
I think institutionally it is rich
people thing you know there's there's
been this you know and part of the empty
shadowplay of our politics is you see
conservatives laying into this kind of
30s vision of what the Democratic Party
may have been at one time this you know
this you know place where unions are
all-powerful where you know class
warfare is always the order of the day
and you know you all you have to do is
look at the Obama administration's
economic rudder record to know that's
not the case you know that you begin
with you know three of the major
culprits in the meltdown Larry Summers
Ben Bernanke tim geithner we're all you
know given positions of maximal power
and influence so you know tell me where
if there's class warfare there it's
being waged from on high talk about the
places you work mother jones in these
times you've written for the bath way no
doubt but but i mean do they is the left
as its represented by those types of
periodicals is it still vital even
within kind of a liberal political arena
if it's represented by those periodicals
it's not vital right so where where is
the left vital I don't think you can
accurately say that it is in order for
the left to be vital it would have to
return to some version of you know and
this is where the right has much more
energy a popular protest movement you
know there I don't understand on many
levels why I mean I understand
intellectually why the Tea Party movie
movement has you know galvanized so much
support because it's tapped into this
anti-government strain I don't
understand why you know people loosely
alive with the left are kind of the
party of you know the status quo is
there any sort of meaningful coalition
possible between a kind of broadly
defined libertarian movement and a
broadly defined look but I think so I
think you saw moments of it during in
our the resistance to the Iraq war I
think they're you know I think those you
know the coalition is kind of contingent
probably more because I you know in
ideological terms libertarianism is
probably stronger it has you know it
knows what it stands for knows what it's
against I'm not sure that you know
liberals or the left have that kind of
well it liberals on the left or two
different beasts aren't they
increasingly less though I think you
know one would want a left that serves
as a kind of conscience to liberalism in
the same way I imagine that many
libertarians think of themselves as the
conscience of the conservative movement
you need institutions you need an
ideology that pushes things forward
that's good I would like to thank Chris
layman author of rich people things for
talking to reason TV today I'm Nick
Gillespie